seulement 17% des maires de communes
sont des femmes les start up fondée par
des femmes enlevées que 2% des
investissements depuis 2008
des chiffres révélateurs évoqués lors de
cette soirée consacrée à l'engagement au
féminin organisé par le député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
le panel c'était aussi l'idée de montrer
des femmes de toutes maturités tous les
âges avec tous les types d'expériences
qui viennent environnement très
différent des yvelines pour montrer que
c'est possible de s'engager et que
probablement plus voir les femmes en
termes d'engagement fera évoluer la
cause de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
une soirée débat accueillis par
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
sensible à ces questions d'égalité elle
organise par ailleurs un cycle de
conférence pour présenter les recherches
sur les inégalités entre les sexes
les rencontres du genre l'engagement
féminin donc aussi bien dans la ville
universitaire que dans la société civile
c'est un des enjeux de la mission parité
de l'université qui a vocation seulement
à permettre l'engagement des étudiants
et des personnels mais également des
futurs citoyens donc c'est important
pour nous de participer à la réflexion
au delà de l'enceinte de l'université
après les présentations des différents
parcours des femmes invitées des
échanges en lieux revenant notamment sur
la nécessité d'être accompagné par la
loi pour plus d'égalité et l'importance
de l'éducation comme levier d'action
pour le changement est important
aujourd'hui d'avoir une représentativité
des femmes et de leur donner un temps de
parole le roc 3 n'y qu'on aille la
chercher
et cette initiative a été pour moi
quelque chose de positif et allant dans
ce sens là une soirée pour promouvoir
l'engagement qu'aimerait renouveler le
député objectifs pour la prochaine
attirer plus d'étudiants
les professionnels de demain